he's been nothing but an inspiration to
a generation of Broadcasters trying to
be him trying to you know follow it the
the inspirational journey that he has
taken to be the legend in the booth
Funny or Die chronicled his life and
times and career a few years ago and
they're still doing it is that right oh
yeah oh God well now it's blossomed into
an IFC series
season 2 already season 3 & 4 is being
picked up because Jim Brock Marv the the
great he's here on the Rich Eisen show
good to see you Jim
good to see you rich as Ananda boy went
down when I first met you hmm we
recorded in a closet and now look at you
got this that's nice to know we did we
were in a closet there were brooms and
cleaning materials in there and now
we're at this lovely studio it looks out
onto an office park in El Segundo it's
it's really the big time congratulations
to you well I know and how has how has
your career blossomed Palace thing
everything worked for you so far Liam
for those who might not know I think
you're setting me up to congratulate you
and thank you which honestly I'd like to
do because it did all it started here
appearing on your show all those years
of my pleasure Jim do you know how it
specifically went down was a clip of an
appearance a man on your show was
playing at a gas station somewhere which
is how no that's how that's you prop
that's the majority of your viewership
that's true is get people watching a gas
stations
you're like the you're probably if you
see in this you're probably watching at
a gas station
you're like the shonda rhimes a
petroleum-based entertainment so
congratulations on that but apparently
this is true and I have see executive
okay was trying to find was watching at
a gas station trying to find a way to
mute you which is you know what a lot of
us go through and when I appeared on the
screen and then here we are you know six
months later I'm given the highest
budget in IFC history I was which
consists of a second Nichols and the
phone number of a guy named patches who
doesn't have a camera but he knows a guy
with a camera and now the rest the rest
has been history well thank you Richard
and now I mentioned it when when Hank
Azaria was out here last segment there
he's handsome there's there's a that
there's now a display a Brock Maher
display in Cooperstown as I just
couldn't be more thrilled about the
smile I kind of plaid jacket not this
one but another one that I have worn is
on display as well as my microphone and
well you know it's such an honor you
know what it's like to be honored at the
Baseball Hall of Fame
oh no wait no you don't know but you are
you're in Canada they're in the Football
Hall of Fame right the NFL hall oh no
you're not there either oh my goodness
no it's just me well I don't want to
make you feel worse by describing how it
feels to be honored by your peers but
you can probably guess it feels it feels
pretty darn good but you will of course
never know how good but well no you
might actually thanks Jen you know I
mean there's this you know hope for you
although the switch to electric cars you
know that that's gonna take a healthy
bit out of your gasoline pump viewers
might cheer your career prospects so
yeah maybe the Year Hall of Fame window
that might've closed
well you know what like I said you've
had a second act in your career
obviously like that like seven or eight
um yeah so maybe you know that have to
restart after every weekend almost yeah
so let's let's talk about the current
state of major league baseball let's do
it the Otani mania here just came out of
me that's the only way to express joy
fro talk oh like that yes I I'm not only
on that bandwagon the old time driving
that bandwagon and we're not stopping
till we get to Cooperstown not to rub
salt but you know honestly though the
Japanese they they refer to a pitcher
who can hit as I want to get this right
a neat or you Wendy tore you that's a
that's a samurai term that translates to
swords as one okay interesting
now you know how many times Steph Curry
has been compared to a samurai exactly
none never okay for the first time since
George Brett cut his hair baseball has
somebody cool again and he also Otani is
he's a handsome devil isn't he which is
important to make it in the media I mean
you know you aside you're the exception
the rest of us we need to be handsome
yes you know I look at Mike Trout for
example probably the best player last 50
years but he's got a forehead like a
drive-in movie screen
and it's got dead eyes like like Andy
from Toy Story it doesn't he so we need
Oh Tony yeah we do need like this is
exciting he's a breath of fresh air no
question about it and then did you catch
Bartolo Colon last night catch but as
you know I glad that was exciting
seven what seven point was seven and a
third there's seven flat perfect innings
perfect I walk him in a hit it's just it
defies like he's my my favorite ball
player has been for a long time I am
partial to any professional athlete who
looks disability check fat you know come
on it's like they put a curly wig on a
shaved bear and I just loved every
second of it
I let alone him throwing like that at
Caesar Marvel he's an absolutely he is
actually do you have any you I'm you
mentioned you know Steph Curry
so do you brought Jim Brock Meyer have
any interest in the NBA playoffs none
not a huge fan of the NBA was or the
playoffs because it's for our games and
it's an interminable season which I
thought was baseball's province you know
at least well at least in baseball it's
not you know where you're gonna get the
games are slow its pastoral you look at
the green enjoyed unfolding before you
while you chat with your family and
friends but I mean in basketball it's
like the last 90 seconds of these
playoff games they're like a Judd Apatow
movie it's like no it's like a fun thing
that goes on at least 20 minutes too
long every single time I mean every time
the ball goes out of bounds it becomes
this like weird fetish video we're old
men in striped uniforms watch men with
gigantic hands in slow motion I mean you
know if I want that kind of weird action
I'll go to a sticky booth in Hamburg
Germany has got intended this to knee
the NBA for that I guess that just shows
you again that you've been around a
while
Jim is that what you've been around for
a while we've had a lot of experiences
Jim Brock my hair on the Rich Eisen show
now I'd love to see if I can put to bed
it whatsoever of this long-standing feud
with you and Brent Musburger I mean what
is going on with you Jim Brock Meyer and
Brent Musburger this is my Musburger
face no you can't put that to bed rich
you know what you can't put it to bed
okay cuz he's a punk that's why retinas
buzz mosburger is a P UNK punk now I
know it's it's weird to refer you don't
often hear and 78 year old guy referred
to as a punk but let me make the case
for this okay sure
besides his annoying face in his stupid
voice and just this whole thing yeah
okay Exhibit A
the guy took a dump in my hotel baby
okay need I go farther Punk move but I
can go farther Exhibit B but you know
that have you ever eaten with mono I'm
not I've been around here not around
food no yeah he won't split a check is
what I'm driving at here he itemizes
everything Oh one time I went out Peter
Gammons had all he had was a diet coke
okay
my Musburger charged him a dollar fifty
for it and when when gammon said I
didn't bring my wallet Musburger wrote
out an IOU and made gammon sign it I
mean that's a that's a punk move is what
that is but most importantly Exhibit C
the man is a thief okay Brent Musburger
is a thief
how so stole my line what llamas on this
is for all the Tostitos remember that
these are all the Tostitos my buddy said
that everybody in the business not funny
everybody the business knows that was my
line but he went ahead and used that's
what I always yell when I climax inside
of a woman or when I'm just when I
climax all by myself I can yell that out
you know what I've been trying to get
you to do that for years to yell it out
have you done that yeah Musburger knew
that was my line he used it anyway at
the BCS title game and ever since then
now I have to yell out ruffles have
ridges it's not the same thing
so verdict what's the verdict of all
that what did you take from that he's a
punk Musburger is a punk that's right
but I in all seriousness yes
I'm a little bit worried about him about
Musburger we all know about his it's no
secret that Vegas is a dangerous place
for him where he is now because of his
addiction issue
it's not I'm not talking out of school
this is widely known among broadcaster
house okay is it and the man is addicted
to Kino now is it sounds funny but it's
it's serious I don't know whether it's
the flashing numbers or the ability to
combine breakfast foods we're gambling
but whatever it is it is a sickness and
you just know that every single night at
2:00 a.m. at a perk owes somewhere off
the strip must burgers drinking bad
coffee and he's talking to some 80 year
old redhead named midge the waitress and
he's literally thrown away dozens of
dollars and it's saying mmm so your jet
deep-down concerned about Brent I am as
concerned as you can be about a punk
thieving lying Punk well Jim look maybe
one day we'll be able to put this feud
to bed because all of us in the
broadcasting community it's awkward for
us to be around either one of you and
knowing that that's still sitting
between the two no put the feud to bed I
mean you took a dump in a bed dump in my
bed so if work that's it it's gonna be a
messy thing to put to bed IFC's Brock
Meyer premieres April 25th season two
and then season three and four is
already renewed congratulations stream
season one on Hulu boy I like saying
Hulu it's Jim brakmar Hulu come on
hellooo that's how you could stream it
on on the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience